hello oh no way bro
no [__] way dog
that's not real huh
man what is look we do a formal intro
all right let's just get it over here
all right
that's how we normally start our
interviews let's get it over with right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster oh come on dog you gotta
do better than that I agree with you
thank you sorry man I'm not trying to
tell you what to do you know what you're
doing
but you gotta try harder bro
all right okay all right
hello
and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kissing and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is
already taking the piss out of us it's
the amazing American comedian theobon
welcome to trigonometry you guys have we
call it autism
I don't know what you guys call it bro
but we got it over here everybody's got
it everybody's got it every celebrity
has it when they have a movie coming out
right they get it like the week before
bro they get autism and then the movie
comes out and then they fix it or
whatever you know it's good to be had
man this is the gayest little microphone
it feels like uh it's all up in your
grill oh it feels like a like a the
weakest one-armed black kid is trying to
give me a hug that's what it feels like
dude like if you go like this
so like whoa somebody feed this boy and
then bring him back to the hug ring you
know because he ain't ready for [__]
real too warm this dude ain't really
hugging with one arm would you rather go
to jail for one year or go to jail with
a Rubik's Cube and you can leave when
it's done oh man
[__] bro a science one huh I would
rather
I go to jail for a year I think it'd be
great
these days relaxing get some reading
done
you know get in shape
you know
yeah get some diverse friends
okay how long
a Rubik's Cube
I bet I could probably do it in a week
oh dude I'd love to have some time to
just relax honestly and I'm a pretty
simple man as long as yeah if I'm in
there I heard the lights are on at night
though that would be the part that
wouldn't give yeah and I grew up in a
mixed neighborhood dude and uh black
people don't really know they don't
differentiate between indoors and
Outdoors
what do you mean Outdoors can be indoors
dude what do you mean Outdoors can be
indoors black person you can put them
outdoors and you put them indoors same
volume levels same speed there's no
inside voice there's no there's zero
inside there's no etiquette when you go
indoors well they just don't I don't I
don't believe in like a lot of
structures and I don't know if I don't
want to say woodwork but I want to say
overall that they the difference between
indoors and Outdoors when it comes to
most so incredibly it's so incredibly
vaguely racist it's so funny though
virgin power is so strong bro oh dude
that's crazy oh hey uh somebody parked a
Volkswagen Rabbit on this guy's leg one
time outside of our Schoolhouse and I
saw a virgin [__] lift it right off
his leg Wild
I've never seen a virgin pick up a car
yeah they'd pick up AK-47s now that's
the problem bro The Virgins now are
picking up AR-15s I was young people
were born you'd have a buddy missing a
uh
you know you'd have you'd have a buddy
missing a clavicle you know you'd have a
friend you know it wasn't crazy to shake
somebody's hand and only feel four on
them you know
it was a different time somebody people
were uneven right somebody missing half
a Cossacks or half of a damn you know
have a square occipital
orbital
entrance you know somebody you know have
a damn Square Eye
it was just different times people had
rabies uh
what else they had people had
diseases uh you know I grew up they had
this the tail into polio you'd see
somebody dragging themselves down you
know dragging you know maybe they had a
cane or a cane somebody got him a cane
that was too short and so they you know
somebody out there short Canaan just
barely might as well just
I mean look like you know might as well
just drag themselves if you're short
came it looks like you're doing damn
magic like you're out there just you
know right I remember I got on a school
bus one day and the man didn't even take
us to school he just drove us around and
uh [__] off swear to God and then just
drove us back home eventually what's
wrong with it he didn't say anything
either probably drunk I remember the
first time we had a conversation you
were talking to somebody about being a
kid and playing gay chicken oh yeah you
know when I was young we used to play
this game called Gay Chicken they called
it uh I didn't name the game but I was
you know I've I the game existed and
then I I then I existed
um was it your uncle was a neighbor well
the game was you you and a buddy you'd
grab each other's wiener right penis
they called her in those days some of
you guys call it penis but uh yeah you
grab it and the first person to get an
erection lost the game right
so it's like arm wrestling first it's
the stupidest [__] kid no it's not no
symbol I mean it is did you win did you
ever win or did you lose did you lose a
lot or did you win a lot oh I did real
well one season uh what is the gay
chicken season what does that go from
it's more of a win I would say it's an
Autumn game
[Laughter]
I can see it now all the leaves changing
colors and just the two of you do you
play with neighbors or their teams no
you just got them you only had about
seven guys that played in our little
bracket or whatever but they had you
know what's weird you know what's
interesting you have seven guys in your
bracket yet it's uh two-man game yeah
and so there's an odd number oh yeah
does it have to be two-man can't you
like do it in a circle oh come on lady
no
come on man that's y'all are messing up
it'll cure Down syndrome bro I beat it
I used to beat it well there's a lot of
rumors in my town that I beat down
syndrome
really yeah
well that's inspiring man that's how I
felt when I heard him because I didn't
start him
and so yeah we we we go we first of all
we get to the airport and they're taking
us on a jet I mean this thing Puma put
us on a jet
and it's uh I mean this thing was long
this thing had two bathrooms in it
and I pissed in both of them because you
know that boy
if there's I'll piss in it you know what
I'm saying I'm pissing at each end of
the yard baby
and I'll let the devil do the laundry
baby you know what I'm saying I'm
pissing when I get in something
that's always who I've been
you know as a child at night before I go
to bed I'd piss off each side of my bed
and I'd piss around it fraud stand on my
bed and urinate around it
just uh to keep
you know whatever bad stuff could come
get me to keep it away did I want to
start focusing on learning more Spanish
so I can uh I want to do a special uh
Spanish yeah like a Nicaragua or
something my dad's from Nicaragua so I
want to do a special in Nicaragua yeah
your dad is not nick
uh we might have to edit that out dude
because
that time closer okay go one more time
but I want to see how racist this ends
up Nicaragua whoa bro a couple of guys
just shut up at the door dude how do you
say it you can't even speak on Kratom
can you Jesus Christ
one
[__] why do you no you're not bro Mike
you're a Hawaiian and from downtown
no I knew dude I mean you know I grew up
around some [__] real crazy poor
white people you know the dude no all if
they had a dude in our town no arms used
to [__] fight everybody you know that
dude you know what I'm saying he'd get
you in that Lurch he would catch you
with his between his chin and his chest
he would [__] snack you like a snake
we were talking about this dude the ass
boy Gert was his name and he would just
get you like that bruh and he'd choke
you down he had Noir no arms at all and
he'd fight anybody dude and he would
choke you he would show if you went to
punch him how would he block oh bro he
spent out of it he'd spin he duck he
dodged the dude had I mean he just will
he catch your hand with his neck huh
what do you catch you oh he would just
alert at you and bro the thing is here
was that oh you know what if he hits you
with that shoulder you're going down
yeah part of it the big room was that
choke he would get he would catch you
like this where would he catch you your
hand that
he would catch you neck to neck
that's [__] crazy once he got you
neck to neck Gert you but this whole
family the whole family was [__] he
could choke you out psychos bro brother
it's sharpened half of his teeth on one
side of his mouth dude these people
would [__] you up one of the kids was in
a wheelchair just they never taught him
to walk I think I don't even think he
was crippled that it's never taught him
to walk and so the other brother would
carry him on his back everywhere like a
backpack dude and didn't even give a
[__] unfortunately almost knocked this
young lady up that was from South Dakota
and she lived on a reservation yeah and
she like threatened to have the baby
oh damn how old were you
37 this year
it was this year and she wouldn't even
be cool she wouldn't she threatened to
have the baby dude and I just met her at
a motel
which fictional character would you love
to be
beat the [__] out of dude I don't know
if I can beat a lot of people I think I
could beat that dude from the mask ever
seen that movie mask with Rocky Dennis I
could fight that dude I bet
who else probably Rosie O'Donnell that's
not a fictional character that's a real
person depends on your ass bro
you know you'll piss what you need right
into the damn bed milk I used to piss
that into the sheet
you know lunch I'd write just piss you'd
wake up and I'd roll over and pull back
the top sheet and I just said just
cleanly pissed
just damn just wiener calligraphy come
right out of me lunch right on the sheet
damn
so if you're a therapist you could have
pulled off that tie every week you could
have seen what I needed
launch oh
uh field trip signature on document that
took me that'd take me three nights to
urinate that into the thing
but Mom would be gone I wouldn't have
nobody would be there to sign it for me
so I just falsified dude I was in
Louisville one time I came out of a show
they had a big group and a limousine
they invited me to go to an after party
with them right I was like I'm only
coming if my boy can come in like who's
your boy and I'm like La Cedric they had
a brother nearby right wearing this
Louis Vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and I
didn't even talked to this dude right I
was like yeah that's my boy like all
right he can come so I [__] walk over
him looking right in the eyes and I was
like what's up man I'm Theo he's like
Cedric and uh I was like all right dude
I told these people you're my friend you
ever been in a limousine he's like nah I
was like all right come get him with us
just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there hot chicks dudes people [__]
little Cedric kept saying we're friends
that's what he kept saying out loud
right kind of [__] not the best actor
bro what did we get to this house party
it's a nice cool [__] party bro I'm
downstairs I'm in the kitchen somebody's
making us a drink I'm talking to
somebody
[__] is six minutes later right here
[__] somebody scream I hear a window
break right
it comes running down they said some
dude just stole like four verses
out of the coat room upstairs
and [__] jumped out of window
that would have been me Doug and that
was [__] little Cedric bro
uh and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like Furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something I remember she got pissed she
was a tough girl she was like one of
those uh what are those people that
slide the thing on the ice she said
curlers because she was a curler
but I was
in my head I was like this is the best
[__] night ever
dude I I could not I just don't even
think I could fight man I remember one
kid attacked me once in school it didn't
go really well I gotta attack a bunch of
dogs
dogs that's a different animal yeah but
literally literally yeah
two of them came back and attacked me on
my birthday again A year later uh on
your birthday I swear to God when they
come back they came back like it's this
Fool's birthday let's you take any bites
uh yeah I took whole bison to the
hospital it's my birthday I remember
when I was 11 years old and then at 12
years old two of them came back and got
me again
like they knew that's what I'm saying
man animals are insightful dude if you
were sent back to the Roman Empire with
a fully charged iPhone do you think you
could take over the world dude
[__] no dude I think they would probably
beat you up they would say you're gay
and they would beat you
man Mexican people work
work hard as hell man I gotta be honest
with you never no complaining just
work hard dude I went to a funeral of a
Mexican guy he climbed out of the casket
dug his own grave hole and then got back
in the casket man if I got to do
something for example I need to build a
picnic table or a
you know edible seating
structure
you know table and I got I got nine
people to help me do it if six out of
the nine people are Mexican bro
Andale Papa we getting it done I'm
telling you that dude I'm telling you
that we gonna be eating lunch early as a
group look I saw a Mexican guy cut down
a tree
make it in the wood bars
bars of wood and then use the wood to
make it he built a damn tree with it
[Laughter]
you look like a deaf guy that goes to
the gym
100 my friends are alcoholics
and I'm competitive
so I have a couple Tequilas right and
Tequila let's be honest like poor Mexico
right in your body okay I mean make you
jump a fence make you buy a gun make you
run across the highway with your family
make you knock a woman up make you knock
a woman down okay Olay Janet you know
dude I got jumped one time after a
football game by five black dudes I
don't know if you ever fought five black
dudes at night
just imagine you're fighting five black
dudes right now close your eyes
now how many black dudes are you
fighting
as many as your imagination can hold
I mean I remember
if I saw like a one I remember my
buddy's mom had a Brazier one time that
she would leave hanging in the bathroom
I'd just go in there to the Brazil oh
bro I would tie it around my [__]
face so that each cup would come over
a little bit of nose but the nostrils
were covered so just the middle oh this
is just that name it's almost like that
Versace The Killing Versace [__] what's
that your nose taint what is this thing
that little part uh your septum no it's
your name isn't it a little bit a little
bit you'd cover up so you can almost
restrict your breathing oh bro so I had
to breathe solely through these [__]
just these straight up titties yeah
that's what you used to like huh that's
[__] milk holsters bro I could smell
the milk I could smell the skin I could
smell the nipple I could smell the
children I could smell all the years of
my buddy growing up what the [__] bro
smell it all dude wow and it would go
straight into my head and that dude I
would jerk when I was someone when I was
young when I'd masturbate I'd pass out
Mr Joe videotaping this hey hey Theo
Theo okay look can you we gonna role
play all right all right you my girl and
you just gonna break up with me oh [__]
break up with me all right break up with
you yeah can I
I'm just asking can I use the N word or
not
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't care but when we step out of
here I can't help
but you using at your discretion okay
[Music]
whatever you want
hey Alice hey hey
what's up baby what's going on you know
what the [__] up boo
my little
[Laughter]
baby why are you censoring the word
[__] you know you're saying
that was A call came in I ain't
censoring [__]
I know you've been out there with Mr Joe
petting them [__] white animals what
what the what baby what
I know you've been out there with Papa
Joe
petting them little [__] honking
Muppets
Shonda you crazy baby look
um not as crazy as your homeless asses
I'm out this relationship my
so so then I just got him to stand up
and I always like making people laugh
like I used to do a similar thing when I
was a child at the lunch table we'd get
some kids who were mentals or a couple
of them might have been mentals and a
couple kids that were well you know when
we get there and sit them to make them
drink milk and then tell jokes and do
stuff and until one of them's just blew
milk out of their face you know
and if you get some straight up just a
couple minerals boy some straight up saw
it off humans you get them to do you get
them to straight up blow leche out there
[Laughter]
that's America right there
you know what I'm saying and that's when
I knew I was like oh I got some kind of
a gift here you know I almost blew the
throat out of this one boy
oh yeah I almost stood up almost blew
the throat out of this this one boy
named tot t-o-t with his name
kind of a bad name too to be mentally
challenged
but also easy for him to spell and
I'm not joking that's what his father
said and
um these rooms smell backward and
forward same name taught
so that's true man it was this guy's
real his name is Todd
why are you so laughing at him it's just
a funny sounding name that's what I'm
saying you're right yeah it was pretty
funny I guess
sometimes you would just say t-o-t was
his name but I knew it was taught yeah
he would try to spell it out you know
like he was tricking me how long would
it take for you to drink all the water
in above ground pool
oh man this is [__] good dude
I don't know man probably
a year and a half
it's a very solid answer you'd be
surprised how many people are like three
days oh no way dude bro and also you
can't drink consecutively can only drink
about a gallon straight before like the
electrolyte in your body switch up and
you can die so dude I drank a gallon at
my buddy Tim's house one time [__]
went to take a nap
bro pissed on his floor
12 by 12 square foot room dude and the
pool touched all four walls bro
I don't know if I had that winter body
type you know I got that thick Upper
Crust you know I have the uh everybody
knows I got the heart of a lesbian my
father told me that when I was very
young and even wrote it one time at a
napkin on a bar over there at Tony
padoni's bar and over at the stinkin
onion which were a couple of small
outfits over there near us he would ride
it on the napkin to remind me a couple
of things about myself I needed to
remember
[Music]
we go get like takavakis to be the kind
of vodka that we would drink it was just
like this off brand in our region like
Todd's almost uh yeah probably like
something like that just like whatever
everybody's had their own little local
brand or whatever this this was called
taka and so you go get a fifth attack or
whatever so one time I'll pull up by the
um gas station and they had this man and
I was thinking oh this guy will buy us
some vodka he looks like he drinks some
vodka and it was daytime you know it's
probably maybe 11 A.M so uh I pick it I
say hey man will you get us some liquor
you say yeah I said all right here's the
money
you got to go in and get the liquor come
back out and get in the car it was kind
of you to give exact directions to yeah
you know otherwise you're gonna deviate
from the plan I buy like some [__] uh
Slim Jims
yeah
[__] the dice yeah
um so anyway he gets back in the car
he's got the liquor and that's when this
dude told me he's like you know I'm the
head button champion in the world right
last thing you want to hear from I'm
talking this guy the only man I've ever
seen yeah he had that thick head oh
this guy's head was probably made by
that Shoemaker right he had that kind of
head heater so you're smaller than
Chin's head Chin's has a dome on it it
was like Chin's head with another chin
on top of it all forehead oh yeah but oh
God yeah it was that jaundice snowman I
was like stacking up a couple of Chin's
heads right this guy had just like you
could see his you could hear his neck if
you put your ear up to his neck he could
his neck would be like man I'm tired you
know oh it's awesome
and you would said button people no he
goes I'm driving us off he has a vodka
and all my I want the vodka from him
right he's trying to get [__] up and
he goes you know I'm the head button
champion of the world right and this
dude's homeless Okay so
until you say I didn't know there was a
competition and this before they had it
this way before this is 20 years before
Kimbo Slice right yeah and this man
looked exactly like Kimbo Slice right
but white with a two-story hit oh he's
black but white or black but black all
right 100 black and he so next thing you
know he goes you know the head button
champion of the world
and you start to see him kind of just
looking at me as I just feel like
suddenly you sizing up your Dome yeah
suddenly I'm looking forward driving and
he's looking directly at me right there
is no us we're not going anywhere
anymore he is just in the car with me
and uh and so I pull and he goes do you
want he goes do you think you could beat
me and I knew
but when he said do you think anything
at that point I'm already thinking about
the cops I'm thinking about funeral I'm
thinking of dude in the back I'm
thinking about it but you can't just get
out of a car when you're driving and
that's one of the issues with cars is
that you have some responsibility to
stay in there at least it's yours
so I still I pull over because I'm not
going to get knocked unconscious while
I'm moving forward you know what I'm
saying I'm not a [__] idiot yeah so
this dude he goes you want to know and I
know he couldn't even hear me anymore
though I'm saying no he's seeing red oh
yeah for him it's game time yeah
I'm saying no in different ways I'm
saying no in different languages and you
can tell it's not registered in his head
and he just lines me up right and just
hit me as hard as he could with his
[__] head bro yeah knock me
completely unconscious only been knocked
out twice in my life once was actually
about three weeks ago when I fell into
the sofa when I was wrestling with some
children the other time was when this
dude the self-proclaiming had button
Champion to the world
[__] put that one hit sleeper on me
bro here's the crazy part he didn't even
touched me with his hands
everything was gone dude everything was
going homeless though yeah that's the
champ though that's the chance how many
people could say he got knocked out by
the jail he's a kind of an honor man
yeah
and my first thought was that dude is
the champ
that's my first thought that's the champ
right there no doubt that man's a
champion we had a teacher I remember he
drew a picture of a wiener ejaculating
oh chalkboard he like kind of described
like he told us what the feelings would
be like we wouldn't be able to handle it
and stuff and then he drew the garage
yeah the ejacula just was he like making
the noise with it I do remember it was
one of those double chalkboards here
comes a big one
I remember he would put the marker on
the board and then walk that's crazy it
was pretty crazy man and he wore the
shortest shorts till he died man Derek
usner was his name or something and I
think his son might have died but he
died son died too I don't want to say
that but I'm pretty sure and he had the
biggest mustache his mustache came over
both lips so it was like some of the
words you just had to guess what they
were some people thought he was black
people don't know what was going on
we just couldn't understand what he was
talking about it was crazy you know it
was just different times back then
dude they have one kid in our in our in
our neighborhood Who uh
uh his dad was a Elvis impersonator
right but in a small town like you don't
work much you know what I'm saying like
if they only have 1100 people in town
nobody needs a [__] Elvis
impersonator yeah for what and he was
really just a drunk you know and he was
hiding behind the costume
but around Christmas they'd let him
dress up like Santa the city would pay
him and he was a seasonal greeter he
would [__] greet people they were
like all right he could pull Elvis off
I'm sure
so but uh and he [__] I remember he
made his son a wooden shirt one time
what
what for Christmas
he made this boy Nathan bro he made
little Nathan a [__] wooden shirt
because I remember holding half of it up
when they [__] nailed him into it
they had to nail him into the shirt he
has a plywood shirt couldn't slide it
over and I'll be honest with you dude
and he loved it he was like the only
thing his dad ever made and probably her
got him I remember he was [__] crying
and [__] tears on top of the [__]
plywood yeah that's ply but it was wood
and it was sanded uh uh it was rough
but over the summer a [__] Hornet's
Nest got underwater
I swear to God when he kept it outside
or something yeah
it could have been a you know rats but I
think it was hornets and then there was
a rumor when I was about 14 that there
was an Asian boy
there was a rumor that was an Asian boy
about 17 miles away from us
and
me and two of my buddies one of them who
had a bad neck his fell out a pretty bad
you know that fifth appendage the neck
people don't think about it you got to
strengthen it and his was
real lean barely hold his head up he
almost had a he almost had to walk
around like this and also hold his head
up with one of his arms
but he and I and another kid
uh got together and decided we want to
go see this Asian you know this room
yeah yeah so we saved up money we cut
grass for about six weeks and saved up
money to get a taxi just to see this guy
yeah okay went to Slidell Louisiana to
go visit him
and we just went to his house no it was
the address that we got oh you you how'd
you get this address dude you can get
information okay okay and this is back
before the internet too this is when
you'd ask around yeah and then guess a
little
and we uh we went to see him and tried
to go see him but it was just a uh it
was a
uh Chinese food restaurant oh he's a
Chinese guy it wasn't a real Chinese
person it was just I think some
kind of white people enhance and it was
like uh
I don't know it might have been like a
Mexican Jewish guy running it oh that's
weird but it wasn't any
no relations
so it's just a minute so we went back
man it cost us about seventy dollars
and then I had some abandonment issues
actually when it came to Asians for a
long time because of that and then the
kid named Jason despour that showed up
when I was in junior high school
and people used to always people they
had this group at the time called whites
against Mexicans and people would attack
him sometimes even though he wasn't
Mexican because he was like closest
thing we had to a Mexican he was he was
Asian but pretty much what was that like
oh my dad was old man my dad was uh 70
years old when uh when I was born wow is
that right thank you for laughing at my
daddy
that's right he really was uh which my
mom was 32 which basically makes me a
product of loose skin and loose morals
[Applause]
here yeah but it was cool though like
the quality time we would spend like
after uh after I was born my dad had a
stroke so we were both learning to walk
at the same time
we have like we'd have like little races
for cookies you know and uh
and uh we
we play games like catch or don't
and uh and my favorite is Dad's sleeping
or is he no longer with us
this is a crazy is you can Vape inside
most people look at me like let me hit
it all right yeah mostly I think most
people just don't care like imagine
light up a cigarette inside of a
Cheesecake Factory they've been probably
tough I mean look on the FBI for sure
yeah yeah I don't think yeah because
vaping people usually blow it down their
pant leg or blow it like yeah the
turtleneck out somewhere yeah yeah and
there's even shirts I saw where it's
made for Vaping secretly vaping
it's like a uh vaping shirt they have
pocket tees that hold your Vape in the
corner
no I'm talking about hold the [__]
smoke oh damn that ghillie suit I'm
telling you there was a dude next to me
who didn't give a [__] on the flight
people would be sleeping on flight full
smoke that's a black dude bro
just say what you want to say you know
sometimes you catch a boy in a
neighborhood or something got a little
bit of um autism you know the tism they
say it and if you give them a little
Hammer you know they had a boy in our
area that's born in Wild Jacob you know
we'd run around and pick berries and
everything in the summer and you know
when the berry bushes really started to
flourish you'd catch him out there with
the blue you know the black dye on his
hands picking berries and uh and eating
them that's the problem his mom gave him
this little hat and he's supposed to put
the berries in there but he would have
just eat them immediately and he'd get
home and he dude have you know 120
berries in his stomach but uh at one
time his uncle I remember passed through
town or something gave him a little
hammer and I mean I swear to God we
thought we had a damn woodpecker in the
neighborhood for probably four years but
while Jacob would just get off in the
woods and he'd find him a little tree or
something or a little you know area of
hardness maybe a fence board or a Grana
and he would just hit it with that
hammer he would look like a guy that
should be much whiter than you are and
you and you know that and you know that
yeah yeah what's the deal dude are you
outside a lot huh are you outside I'm
outside man yeah part of my feelings
from Nicaragua bro that's not a racial
sir yeah my father's Nicaragua what yeah
Nicaragua bruh where my neck guards at
huh well
a little too close okay sorry yeah and
hopefully the audio is clear on that
yeah it is okay
there's a c in there I want to thank
everybody from fighter and the kid you
know I was uh and that's a a podcast
where they had this man who is a fighter
and he got he got beat up and he got
attacked a couple times and he couldn't
fight anymore because his brain couldn't
handle it he was on the brisk of
freaking getting that you know abrush
with that tysm and so his brain you know
told him we got to shut it down and so
he quit fighting and he met up with this
other man who's kind of Aging but he's
just you know a sweet funny guy and he
got strong legs the other guy and their
names are Brendan and Brian and the
podcast is called the fighter and the
kid
and one of them uses moisturizer
and one of them needs moisturizer